on Tony Burns I'm the team leader for
the
team Gore
which I quite often call it gallblacks
Eileen and
I've only been driving since November
last year and there's some real
characters and I just love meeting
everybody it's great I'm Jim I've been
doing the shuttle for St John's this is
my fourth year now you get to know
people quite well in the community and
um
they get quite a kick out of being able
to do something for people in the
community so so for anyone watching that
might not know exactly what you guys do
what is the St John's shuttle service
you know the shuttle has been going for
quite a long time
but you just don't people just don't
take notice you see the yellow cars sort
of coming you through too you don't know
what they're there for and you haven't
needed that service yeah
take them to Dunedin we take them to
Milton we take the balclutha
we'll take them over to Winton the only
thing we don't do is
take people to
um appointments in town people say you
know we just could not
get to our appointments if you guys
weren't doing it
and that goes for the people who are
normally quite able-bodied but they're
just not allowed to drive because
they've got drops in their eyes or
something like that what was the
appointment as something to do with
medical eyesight hearing hospitals yeah
the people who are just no longer able
to drive
at the gore Council
yeah yeah so you're you're on coffee and
chocolates I'm afraid
okay give
proteog boss how do you volunteer we
we'd love to have some more drivers
please come and have a chat
any one of us or at the Depot in
Charlton Road love to see you